spoken to Tim Davey yet Mr lineker yet
another day of chaos swirling around the
BBC's biggest paid star have you spoken
to the BBC yet Gary the man himself
tight-lipped over what might be next
sorry pressure is growing on the BBC
director General Tim Davey who's flown
back from Washington to try and get a
grip but the whole Affair has brought
attention firmly back to the BBC's
chairman Richard Sharp embroiled in his
own impartiality Rye if you compare it
to what happened with Richard Sharp the
chairman of the BBC a few weeks ago when
it was discovered that he had helped
facilitate an 800 000 pound loan for the
Prime Minister Tory MPS and Tory
Minister said nothing to see here that's
totally fine
the lineker and sharp cases are in some
ways completely separate for one thing
the BBC itself has no control over the
appointment of the BBC chair is a
government decision but on the other
hand they are intimately related
perceived as two sides of the same coin
in the Raging debate over BBC
impartiality BBC Radio 5 had to play
podcasts to fill holes before returning
to normal service later good afternoon
I'm Aleister Bruce match of the day two
tonight is expected to be a shadow of
its former self Ian's right about you
just got to win a game and some of the
BBC's usual faces popped up elsewhere
as so where it all goes from here one
former BBC executive had this advice
whether the guidelines themselves are
sufficiently robust or clear and need a
certain amount of Revision in a world of
social media in 24-hour news and all the
rest of it I I think there's a case for
that so um no I think they've made these
decisions in the way they thought best
but on the hoof against an awful lot of
pressure the political hate hasn't
helped from all sides
the BBC may be in crisis but there are
solutions the trouble is there are few
that will leave everyone satisfied